you know when you were watching the
khabib and gaichi what were you uh
what do you think after that first round
because i felt like gaechi got a lot of
time on his feet against him
a lot of it got a lot of guys don't get
that it seemed like do not get as much
time against khabib on their feet
yeah no and i think i think that's that
i think that was the most surprising
thing is is we thought
the striking was going to lean towards
gaichi's favor
yet khabib i think the manner which
could be
fights is just hectic crazy fast pace
it's not that skilled if you go back and
watch the fight there really wasn't a
ton of
strikes that were landed they landed on
justin's hands they landed on
justin's elbows forearms like it wasn't
like he hurt
uh gaichi numerous times he just got i
think he just got gate she's scared and
i hate
using the word scary because i don't
like to talk about the guys in my
division
right obviously just not a guy who gets
scared but i know what you're saying
that that nerd that energy in the
beginning or it's even like
who was i just talking to oh uh well i
was talking to brendan about it i think
like it it's almost like if you get
thrown into a scenario where you're not
you're just not
ready you can make bad decisions you
know and i think justin gaichi also just
was making bad decisions on the ground
so i don't think necessarily i think
justin gaichi is that bad on the ground
i think he just got there and he was
just like what do i do this guy's nuts
you know this guy's a freaking
mauler yeah he's like a rare snake kind
of yeah exactly
they're like why haven't scientists
found this dude yet you know it's kind
of like
it's almost like you would see him more
on one of those like david attenborough
kind of like yeah
you know the david the russian anaconda
then you would like it seems like he
hasn't been discovered it's like well
somebody test this dude yeah he's like
never reptilianism yeah
or like or like 3 000 miles below the
sea level yeah yeah bottom of the ocean
somewhere
he's running on some old water when
you're watching that fight did you think
um at all and i'm a novice fight watcher
you know i'm new into like just even
absorbing a lot of what you guys world
is like and it's and the biggest reason
is just because it's something that so
scared me my whole life like any like
physical altercation
like never learned how to defend myself
never learned any of that growing up
nobody even
in my ear like hey just at least stand
there and get hit you know none of that
so
i definitely come from a place of
fascination did you
think when you were watching the uh
khabib and gachi that that could be kind
of let the first round happen do you
feel like he could have finished it
earlier or do you feel like um
it just that the way it played out was
the way it played out i think the way it
played out was the way it played out
because i think i mean i think
habib just was going and going and just
turned it into a fight
real quick fast paces it and i loved it
he just fought with reckless abandon and
this is a guy who's undefeated
most of the time you see guys who are
undefeated protect that record
by fighting a little bit more uh
you know a little bit more timid or a
little bit more diplomatic a little bit
smarter you know if you will but he just
went
he went in there and wanted to get into
a fist fight with with you know
the craziest striker in the division who
would you uh was there a rather well
you're like if you started to think like
who would i rather fight
i i my answer to that is i love
i would love the idea of fighting both
of them but at that point you have to
fight khabib just because he's the
number one guy oh wow really
yeah because if you're gonna fight i
mean yeah it would be better to have a
12-week training camp focused just on
habib obviously when you have the
opportunity of a lifetime to
you know beat an undefeated fighter the
best fighter in lightweight history
and get the world title um but for me
you got to take the opportunities when
you can they don't just hand out ufc
you know title fights like it's nothing
so um
for me it would have been habib just
because i would have had the opportunity
to capture the belt that night
uh and a fight with me and justin gaity
is going to happen just like i said the
fight with me and poyo is going to
happen these fights are going to happen
but so if you had the opportunity and i
knew we all knew habib we didn't know he
was going to retire that night
or at least say he's going to retire we
don't know yet but
i thought for sure he's going to have
one maybe two fights left in him so you
want to i want to get that fight before
he retires
i would not want to get that fight but i
brought but but that's
different mindsets man now is when
you're there and you're in that
environment
is there a level of royalty that kind of
proceeds and surrounds khabib that
doesn't surround anybody else in a way
no i yeah i'm not i'm not really i'm not
that you're thinking
but do you feel is there anything like
that in the air no i'm just wondering
well he wasn't there that much to be
honest with you like i saw
justin gates a couple times his mom and
dad were there his brothers his brother
looks just like him they're all from
arizona they're kind of doing their
thing
man me and justin gates are very similar
man small town
blue collar wrestling families like
that's
it looked like my family walking around
if we were in in abu dhabi at a
at a hotel somewhere so he was there he
was
present and he was seen a lot had a
couple conversations with him or his
team or whatever
habit was nowhere to be found habib had
like his own training facility he had
his own
hotel he had his own everything he
showed up in armored cars and
motorcades and helicopters and all kinds
of stuff so
he is like royalty over there because
it's middle east it's close to russia
he's he's
uh muslim you know so he's he's like
royalty so there
there is but for me as like a red white
and blue blood in america i'm like
this is silly man right now it's like
whatever
right so but you got to respect it now
i don't i don't want to i don't want
that to come off like i don't respect
him like i respect him a ton as a
competitor inside the cage what he's
done
his accomplishments plus winning his
last fight after the loss of his father
and all that kind of stuff i respect him
respect the heck out of him for that but
for the most part he was like man it's
just like all right bro
and i don't know he showed up he looked
like a skeleton at weigh-ins he looked
like
it was it was questionable whether he
even made weight wow you know you're
just like
dude be a professional make the weight
show up
with your chest puffed out and a smile
on your face do your job yeah there's a
video where it says it looks like they
didn't even check his weight kind of
did you supposedly they did you know did
you i mean
does that seem normal to you did it feel
i mean i will say i will say daniel
cormier brought this up
and it is true they at the hotel i had
to step on the scale
and i weighed 154.9 and uh
then they said okay you can get on the
bus so if i was 155.2 or whatever there
they might have been like no you know
you can't get on the bus until you cut
the weight
then again maybe habib was like i'm
right at 155.1 by the time i get over
there i can float point one maybe the
scale it's a a lot of times your balance
scales you know those old-school balance
scales are a little bit more lenient
than
your digital scale because the digital
scale will tell you point boom whatever
it is right
the balance scale all they have to do is
have a little bit of daylight
and you're technically in there so
there's almost like a 0.2 swing
yeah um but yeah i mean he stepped on
the scale it was going up
they swiped it and but it's you know
it's conspiracy theory
yeah i mean it's it's man they've been
doing this for 26
27 years you know there hasn't been many
controversies so
whatever it wasn't meant to be for me to
step inside the occasion nor would i
have
if khabib didn't make weight at that
moment he would have got time to cut
weight anyway so
i wasn't worried about it good evening
good afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or
watch this one watch this one watch this
one watch this one
ah